emmanuel is with us in Minnesota hi
Emmanuel how are you hi Dave I'm great
hi Rachel thanks for taking my call yeah
absolutely Thanks
what's up so I have the situation where
so me and my fiance are getting married
on Saturday and we're looking at the
financial piece in University and we've
been following some of your content I'm
really watching a lot of your videos and
I have an extremely irregular income I
do sales for a construction company so
it's all commissioned last year I made a
decayed pre-tax and I'm trying to figure
out how to budget that the right way
because someone's at 15 K some someone
to zero and winters practically zero
from like November until March yeah and
then you got coronavirus hiccup in the
middle of it right yeah yeah does she
work outside the home what'd she make
she does were actually pretty young but
she makes last year she made about 15 K
okay so how old are you guys I'm 21
she's 20 what does she do she used to
work at a bank but she quit that because
she wants to go and turn for accounting
I was reading in foreign she's got a
game plan to get her income up great
Yeah right very good you guys are on
fire I'm proud of you good stuff thank
you thank you so well first thing is
we're gonna give you Financial Peace
University as our wedding gift we went
on no way once you guys to go through it
and have a year membership to be able to
continue to do and look at the videos
and learn everything man if I'd learned
that at 20 and 21 years old I would have
been a freaking genius by now and so
we'll give you got guys that and get you
started and then Rachel what do they do
with their regular income yeah well I
would say number one congratulations
getting married in the middle of 19 so I
know it's a memory that's two in a row
it'd be a small wedding that's right
that's right the other ones it too yeah
so what you got to do is yet what you're
saying is you just have to plan and so
when you're making more of your 80 grand
in certain months you have to be very
diligent to set some of that aside to
say okay that's gonna go into savings
and in the months is what you're pulling
out of savings so it just takes a level
of intentionality and like even for me
I'm on mostly Commission and so mine is
very seasonal as well summer and you
know that I have seasons of the years
I'm like yeah I'm not making as much
other seasons I am and so I do have to
be very my husband I both would talk
about it and we have to be very very
specific with okay we're gonna set some
of that aside because if we need to pull
anything during those low months we have
the cash to do it so it just takes a lot
of diligence in the planning process but
it is still possible to budget even with
an irregular income and on the months
that is low I mean I would even
encourage you guys to make sure your
four walls of course are covered and
everything else but you will have to
prioritize because there may be a month
there like you know what we're gonna cut
some things out of here just because it
is other months we don't take as much
out of saving so you'll see it kind of
shift your spending patterns as well and
so that's really really important to
watch when Sharon and I were first
starting this budgeting stuff we were
living like you guys are living I was
doing real estate deals and I had
nothing or 20,000 in a month I mean it
was extremely volatile not just mildly
value and that's what you're describing
here so what we learned to do was
separate from the baby steps not
counting your emergency fund not
counting your normal baby step process
we set aside a different savings account
and it's a dumb name but it's the only
name we could come up with we called it
the hill and valley account the hills
are when really good month and the
valleys when it's a really sucky month
right and so I need to be able to cover
with the good months cover the bad
months and so we set aside some money so
let's just pretend for a second you do
your budget and you figure out I need
three thousand dollars a month that's
$36,000 a year out of your hundred
thousand just to make my bills okay and
and I the chances of me having two
months of zero are almost zero I mean to
z consecutive zero months are very
unlikely and so I'm gonna set aside
$3,000 in a Hill Valley account in case
I had a down month or a zero month and I
can at least make my monthly amount and
then pass that I'm just gonna use my
income
work the emergency button now if you
think two consecutive months of zero are
possible then your Hill Valley account
would be 6000 in our example I don't
know whether 3,000 is the right amount
but if that's an example but if you set
aside and say all right we can make our
monthly bills with $3,000 a month and
I'm you know the chance of having one
more than one month of zeros is zero so
we're gonna do one month or we're gonna
do two months because you know that's
the most it could ever be and that's not
your emergency fund that's a separate
account from emergency that's to cover
the volatility in your income on the
valley months from the months when
you're on the hill again
dumb name that's all I could come up
with